[Music]
American Airlines is getting a lot of
unwanted publicity for an issue
involving loose seats yes apparently
seats aboard several of their planes
have become unhinged in flight and
everyone's talking about it needless to
say this is a rather frightening issue
and I thought we should check in on this
see how it's going I'm told an American
Airlines flight landed 20 minutes ago
at LAX some of the passengers are
departing around now and what's just I
think we have a camera crew over there
let's check it out see how it's going
[Applause]
[Music]
it can you imagine how like flying isn't
scary enough I know you know American
Airlines you need to get your act
together you need to stop
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a great show tonight
[Applause]
from juno 13 going on 30 in the new
field butter Jennifer Garner is here
[Applause]
Expendables movies in the TBS series
over there yet Terry Crews is on
music esquina Tara
[Applause]
can you see the guys pushing the chair
[Applause]
put me right back Jimmy take us